let's see if sam is here you know we got
samsung on it with us
will you join who has just won his and
or will you join this guy
sam you had a victory but we want to put
you to work do you think white's winning
this position
no
okay so i'm going to agree with it
i'm going to agree if you want me to
pick now
i get to follow behind
sam sam says
sam said
but okay that's not your job your job is
to win the game you won and you did so
talk to it wait a minute that's not it
uh i've got all you got it i got it up
over
uh you um
this is it right yeah you you
before we get going
you and jeffrey have been rivals for a
long time i mean it's like you jeff you
jeff he's kind of pulled up a little bit
he's at that 2700 level do you have any
feelings about that like you know you've
got to work really hard to show that you
still are keeping pace
yeah for sure i mean i
work very hard and try to get to 2700
myself
uh today's victory what does it mean
in in the tournament itself for you as
this obviously the u.s championship
you're not a you're not a young rookie
anymore you're a big boy now so what
does it mean uh for you to be uh winning
in this tournament what are your
aspirations for the tournament itself
yeah i mean i'm really happy to get on
the board um i had a double weight to
start and kind of scraped out one point
had two tough games and today i had a
tough position too out of the opening he
kind of surprised me early on
but i think at some point he started to
go wrong and i took over the initiative
and before the time control he made some
mistakes
tell us a moment tell us a big moment in
the game you thought that move i have to
take care of business now
i have the position over here and your
monitor yeah we got the position there
oh right where where do we go from here
yeah his positional mistake he should
play quincy too i think
he should play queens when c2 h3 bishop
e3 just developed the pieces like this
queen c2 h3 bishop e3 because queen e3
is kind of awkward for his queen okay
okay then we could go a little bit
so far it looks like
a nebu one is a bad move okay it looks
better for white but there are no real
moves i'm playing rook 88 next and
we looked at it a little bit there's
just no real plan for white so he did
knight be one to play knight a3 knight
c4
but it's just too slow i play
knight d5 with tempo
queen f3 knight b4 with tempo and for
example if a3 i have knight a2 already
tactics
rook moves knight takes b3 and he's just
pinned
and he's pinned down the d file got it
nice
so he played knight c3
i played rook d8 i could have played
knight c6
just to equalize but this is a nice idea
rook 8 first
queen e3 rook d6 really good move
and i was really happy to see it because
now he has no moves and i'm playing
knight c6 next
just equalizing
tell us why you couldn't play knight c6
immediately uh he has bishop takes c6
okay i'm not sure that's a big deal but
it's definitely better to have bishop 66
available for right for you with your
bishop coming out gotcha
so i played rook g6 to open the bishop
a3 knight c6 takes takes
sticks
uh b4 yep now bishop takes g2
if bc5 have queen c6
f3 bishop takes h3 g4
and i think i would play f5 and my
bishop escapes
because he can't go knight f2 if gfg
there's made on g2
that's unlucky
oops
so he played
king takes g2 94 now i just have a
pleasant position
yeah he traded 93 now rook decided to
stop the rook exchange
now we're both kind of low on time i
think he started to go wrong here knight
c4 i think he should play rook c2 king
f3 just play safe yeah it doesn't look
bad for him it doesn't look so bad yeah
i like black but he should hold here
can you have three bishops c1 so knight
c4 now i saw my chance knight a4 rook t2
oh
f6 e5 i just blocked his bishop
now it's now it's really gone south this
bishop on a1 is
very passionate now he took it to pawn
on a3
um
oh b5 was awful yeah
i think he just panicked here
the position is not completely winning
he can try rook c8 check
king f7 rook a8 try to attack my pawns
at least
i mean i should be winning but
it's still a game it's it's his best
opportunity to try to hold on
but after bishop d6 b5
now it's
two extra pawns and
yeah so the reason i played b4 was i
just wanted to get the rooks off towards
so i don't have to calculate much so if
knight d5 if bishop takes b4 i have
bishop takes f4 gf rook b2 right
that's a nice and this should be pretty
easy exactly that is a nice
and the game he played knight d5 rugby
two again if he takes them just healthy
b pawn clear
here yeah b5 is a nice finishing touch
just the beep on queens
well done young man thank you very very
nice very nice how how do you feel now
about the tournament oh definitely much
better
which number of the us championship is
this for you sam uh i think this is my
fifth so you're still quite the veteran
yeah you're 20 years young
turning into very good
well well done congratulations you're
tied for first and uh good luck the rest
of the way thank you absolutely
and